how hard was it to discover that you had
a scary resemblance to Kermit the Frog
it was way scarier than you think
because at the same time that happened I
was plagued by all sorts of frog
occurrences and so that was something
God it was weird and awful but it
started out really funny because when I
first posted my lectures on YouTube I
noticed now and then that someone would
say he sounds like Kermit and I thought
yeah no then I listened and I thought oh
my God
I sound a lot like Kermit and then I got
associated with Pepe the Frog and that
was pretty bloody weird and then my
Indian Carver friend made me a frog mask
and I made a video with that on and the
Frog mask looked a lot like peppy even
though he didn't even know who Pepe was
so that was Bloody weird and then Dad
bought a peppy flag and flew it at the
lake this 80 year old guy Pappy
[Laughter]
Jesus